what to get me for my birthday so is my
birthday coming up on May twentieth it's
also Christina's birthday we have the
same birthday she's my video editor does
a lot of this stuff over the years I've
gone from wanting products to wanting
experiences to wanting impact and so
when I was younger I wanted stuff I
wanted toys right I wanted new shoes or
new computer or new clothes or whatever
it was and as I got older became less
and less important one I can go out and
get whatever I needed and I would just
buy it if I wanted it there's nothing on
my list of like I wish I could go and
buy this thing and 2 i've been getting
rid of stuff like i have too much stuff
people are sending me stuff it's a good
problem to have i guess but i want to
pare down I don't need as much stuff
anymore to be happy and so I don't want
people to send me stuff as a birthday
present I moved to experiences and
experiences mores more like hey let's go
enjoy baseball game together or let's go
on a vacation or let's learn how to
snowboard give me a certificate for the
winter will go snowboarding and I still
like that stuff and I still appreciate
and still like it more than products
again like if I wanted to go do
something I can go do it you know i
don't i don't like being away from
toronto for too long it's too much
important stuff I'm doing here there's
no new experience that I really am like
dying to try out and if I was I would
just go out and do it we're when I'm
moving more and more towards this impact
like the thing that gets me excited is
knowing that I'm helping somebody like
I've having a meaningful impact in their
life somehow so earlier this week Alex
from trying to dance salsa asked me what
can I get you for your birthday it's
coming up tell me what you want I'm a
guy you're a guy you're a bit on the
bush is tell me what you want I'll go
out and buy it it's Alex I don't need
anything don't buy me anything the
biggest thing you do is just do
something that's on your bucket list do
something that you know you're afraid of
or you've been putting off for too long
go out and do that and let my birthday
be the excuse for you to go out and do
it and so he's been looking in the sky
diving did you book it tandem right
you're gonna be strapped so the biggest
thing that you guys could get me you
know if you're looking at doing
something is I'd love for you to look at
your list of things that you really want
to do so
and it's on your bucket list something
that you're afraid of doing and just do
it like let this be the excuse to
actually go out and do it don't wait
five years for it to happen don't keep
putting it off take one thing cross it
off and do it and tell me what it is
even if you haven't done it yet
something that you've now like taking
action to plan to do it leave in the
comments below that would really make my
birthday super special please please
please take action I want to have some
impact beyond what I'm already doing so
thank you guys so much you have been an
insane source of joy for the past year
and I'm looking forward to another 10 20
30 40 50 years of doing this continue to
believe and I'll see you soon